[Music]
okay everybody i am so so so excited
today because i get the privilege to
talk with curran walters about the
latest episode of titans and you know
him as jason todd aka robin aka red hood
we're talking about episode five so a
lot of spoilers here so make sure you
watch that first and come back
karen how you doing today man
yeah i'm amazing thank you for having me
i appreciate it
oh hell yeah man you know i was so
excited to talk to you in particular
because i'm always a big fan of whoever
i'm interviewing what they got going on
in the background and you always got a
surprise and it's a six set up you got
with the red hood and the baseband
hey only if you saw it was behind the
cameras it's too much [ __ ] but yeah i
got i got the cool red hood helmet and i
got this amazing painting so
yeah that's fun man
dude that that's amazing and it's so
exciting to see that you love the
character so much and i'm not saying
this to butter you up but it was my
favorite episode of titans yet so
there's a lot going on emotionally
though with jason here so my first
question to you is just in the beginning
of this episode when he's having these
nightmares and bruce says no more rob
until you see a shrink
you know can you kind of just get me in
his head space at this moment where he's
at from where we saw him last end of the
season yeah yeah first of all thank you
so much that means a lot um no problem i
i um
saw jason lead off at the at the end of
season two he would he felt really
betrayed by the titans and you know
especially after rose let him down he
was he was an absolute mess i mean we
saw that scene on the rooftop with dick
and
everything um
you know i think one of the beautiful
things about episode 5 is that we get to
explore that bruce and jason
relationship which brings up your
question of you know when when jason's
with the with the therapist and the
shrink as he would say um
you know it's it's such a touchy subject
to jason because
ultimately
before he becomes red hood he's
he
bruce tells him that he can't be robin
and i think that really touches home to
him because that's where he felt safe
that's where he felt um you know close
to the titans and obviously now with
connecting with jonathan crane and
trying to get away from
the whole robin and then becoming red
hood he's struggling now with
what he wants to be he wants to go back
to be that old robin but now he he's
trying to move on so he's just
throughout the whole season man we just
see him just
there's so many emotions just what what
is going on you know what i mean this
poor kid
um so that that's such a fun dynamic to
explore throughout the season
yeah and you mentioned him going to
jonathan crane in this episode you see
that he has this moment where it's kind
of touching because bruce is calling him
son but then he basically wants to shut
him down as robin and protect him in a
way from wearing the costume
but when i'm watching scene what is it
when you were approaching says an actor
what was that moment where you like okay
how did you know he wanted to go like
what was his driving force to go to
crane at that point like what what was
it for him
i i think in a way jason felt like this
was his only option and in a way he
wanted to
prove bruce that he was wrong about him
and you know obviously the alleyway
scene we saw that so
i think this was jason's
form of of moving on and wanting to get
rid of his fear and um
you know everything that happened with
him
before super boy saved them you know
almost almost dying and all that um
there was just a lot going on in his
head and you know as soon as he heard
about the fear yes he's like maybe this
this is my only way out maybe this will
help me feel again feel better um
so obviously we see what happens with
that
yeah and and it's crazy because then as
the episode goes on you see he's taking
this antidote to fear that scarecrow
made now i always wonder because you're
such a good actor and
what blows me away is how you hit that
sweet spot where you're not overdoing it
with the serum you're like hitting it
that i'm still invested so how do you
find that where it's that blend of being
the emotions of jason but having this
effect of like a drug on you
yeah man it was just a lot of a lot of
uh alone time spent trying to figure out
what the hell to do um
in toronto i would just pace around my
apartment i was like does this feel
right does this feel right no it's it's
more of that no that's too much that's
too little so a lot of that um you know
just really finding the right balance
and um having such an amazing team on
set it was like you know just does this
work does this not work so it was just
you know it was a big team effort and um
you know i think i think it came out
awesome and the fans are obviously
enjoying it
yeah and i mean i think what's also cool
too is in your big episode here it being
this red hood origin there's a lot of
hints about other batman villains we
always love to see and i thought the
coolest part to me easter egg wise so
far in the show is you opening bruce's
little keepsake
do you still geek out as curran seeing
this stuff when you're on set like holy
[ __ ] i'm touching this stuff
yeah i mean hey man like every time i
walked into the batcave i just like
stopped and i was like
the only people will just like die to be
here like in the back cave like
so of course i i kind of geek out on
everything to be honest with you i mean
that stuff is obviously so cool but the
bad cave i get on every time every time
i see like the night in costume or even
my costume like in the in the
suitcase or whatever um
yeah man i'm i'm i'm such a geek now
with all this
yeah and i mean
in this timeline too it's season two to
season three did you always know too
that you were gonna eventually be red
hood or like when did you find out that
was happening
you know
i didn't know throughout season two i
was i was i had a feeling that it would
happen um i had a feeling that you know
how could it not i mean
we already brought jason todd to life it
felt like the only option but at the end
of season two when we got picked up for
season three
they wanted me to come in for a fitting
and that's when i found out you know
we're gonna be making a new costume and
whatnot in a pandemic hit so that kind
of you know pushed everything back like
a year
um but yeah towards the end of season
two we found out and
i was just thrilled i was just so happy
about it so
yeah yeah and you know what i was
excited to see the twist i'm not like
this huge comic book reader so i didn't
even know jason todd even is red hood so
for me i was like my jaw dropped it's
exciting uh and what's cool is when
you're playing red hood there's like
this voice effect i think on you if i'm
pregnant wrong but how is that going
down how is the voice being made for
ready oh that's actually all me
[Laughter]
you know
that was
that was one of the things that was
that was one of the biggest challenges
to me because you know in the mask
as a character you don't want people to
know it's jason but you know and until
you know nightwing and i have that fight
he knocks my helmet off and he's like oh
jason so for me it was
when i was in the helmet
i would make my voice sound deeper you
know it wasn't that much deeper but it
just gave it kind of that more
just
just straightforward like i'm here to do
a job i'm i'm
now a killer like just kind of badass
um voice but you know and then we did a
voiceover in the studio and that's where
we kind of put the effects on it after
to make it sound more muffled and all
that so it was a process i mean every
red hood scene i did basically with the
mask on i had to go do again in the
studio so it was
it was pretty cool there was a lot of
time spent in there and that was new to
me so yeah it was all very fun so what
i'm getting from this too it seems like
uh red hood also has more of its
challenges in that part i mean because
you're you're playing jason you're
playing robin you're playing red hood
yeah having said that what to you is
your favorite to play like what do you
have the most fun doing
they all they all are so much fun i
robin will always have my heart man i
mean
it yeah
that costume and the last time i put my
costume i was like
that was that was very uh that was very
sad but then red hood is so fun you know
it's i always love a new challenge and
figuring out a character and um yeah man
just like everything from because you're
you don't see your facial expressions
when you're when you're in the helmet so
it was like
everything from the head movement to the
way you you looked um to if your head
was too high was it was it's a lot that
goes into it you know so
it's something you figure out over time
and yeah it's fun
did you feel an extra pressure taking on
red hood because it seems like to me
batman fans
they're known for loving the villains so
every time there's a villain betrayal
they want the best this is dear to them
redhead did you feel that did you feel
like this anxiety taking it on
absolutely i'd be lying if i said i
didn't
yeah
i feel that i felt that because i care
so much you know i want to give the fans
and um what they like and what they want
so
yeah um there were there was 10 months
of me in my head is this right is am i
doing this correctly
so now that we're here and then the
episodes are out and the fans love it
i'm i am thrilled
yeah and they love guys you're
absolutely killing it and
i'm going to ask you a geeky question
for those fans is that who is your
favorite batman villain of all time but
you can't say red hood
you got to know where i'm going i mean
the joker
oh you're going joker okay okay the
classic
heath ledger was
he his take on the joker just made me
absolutely love the character
i mean
that was insane and yeah i just i i love
a crazy villain
so that must have been an honor for you
then having this moment as robin where
the joker basically beat you to death
absolutely
i wish we got to actually see the joker
you know so that would be cool to maybe
i don't know go back to maybe
yeah yeah yeah hell yeah um but that's
like people can see
oh yeah
and and man people can see how
passionate you are just in this
interview with what you're doing and
again where i said you have stuff that
in your interviews you have in the
background you post about a lot on
social media
does that help you be more motivated
acting wise does it all add up
yeah man i
i think for me it's it's it's a lot that
goes around this character you know it's
this character means it's so much to me
i mean my dad's name was jason my
grandma's name is robin
robin um yeah so it's it's a totally
it's it's weird how the universe works
so it's this character is
it's it means a lot to me and now being
given the opportunity to do red hood
it's like it's my life you know it kind
of it catapulted catapulted me to the
next step of my career too so i'm just
i'm very very thankful for for this
opportunity
yeah and it's it's great because you've
just shown your worth here in this dc
universe it's such a huge franchise what
i'm also curious about is because you're
a big fan of this stuff are you a fan of
all the other superhero stuff too like
do you watch the boys do you like mcu
does that also kind of catch your eye
would you say you're right yeah i mean
man i like all the spiderman's growing
up i love
um
the batman's i mean i love batman of
course um
the boys is is great is fantastic we
actually have the same costume designers
as the boys which is so cool um but yeah
i'm kind of like slowly getting into all
the superhero stuff i never really was
before this show before i became a part
of this show
um
but i mean how could you not like batman
and the joker and all that you know so
yeah i'm slowly becoming more of a geek
day by day and i love it i love it
that's awesome um
also too besides you're saying you're
being a geek you're very wise on twitter
with great quotes i love and you had one
that you said if you turn i have to into
i get to your life will change yeah
thankful for all the opportunities you
get every day can you kind of elaborate
on this do you go about this every day
um
i saw a uh an interview um of somebody
explaining that and it was like you know
i think we take a lot of things for
granted you know it's like oh i have to
go get my car washed oh i have to go to
the gym or i have to it's like if you
turn these things in like into a
positive mindset like you get to
go to the gym you're lucky that you're
you're able to walk and wake up that day
healthy and all that you you get to go
to work you're given this opportunity
it's just it's just changing that
mindset into ins into
a positive mindset and just looking at
everything
in a brighter mindset it's like i'm
still learning to do that day by day you
know i still have moments like i have to
do this i have to do that but it's like
hey if you switch that your life
i think dramatically changes in the way
you just you see the world differently
so yeah it's important
no and while you're giving this great
wisdom i have to ask too like you've
already proven how strong your acting
chops are and yeah i can already just
tell from your vibe they're a hard
worker but what's driving you to do this
like what is the ultimate dream for you
at the end of the day in your career
like what where do you want to be
yeah man i
i mean i think there's always an end
goal i mean
but i i just want to do this for the
rest of my life i genuinely love working
i genuinely love the creative aspect of
it and everything that goes in from like
you know casting to you know behind the
scenes to
being on camera to
just everything i was just it's a
never-ending process and like even just
being in the studio it's just i
literally just fell in love with this
crap from day one um i think my ultimate
i don't i wouldn't necessarily
necessarily say it's an end goal but i
would love to win you know
an award someday like an oscar or an
emmy and you know i think
yeah it's for me it's like
if you genuinely believe in yourself and
manifest that it's like it'll happen
like i manifested getting my own shows
today and like here i am on titans and
you know who would ever have thought so
it's just i think the universe works out
in crazy ways like that you work hard
and you genuinely love what you do and
you you
you fail and you keep going and you you
fail more and you keep going
it's bound to work out man it's you know
so
we'll see what happens in in in the
future but i'm i'm really excited for
what the future holds i gotta go again
i get a genuinely good feeling
yeah good i do too and i think
everyone's just excited to see what
you're gonna do next in the show because
we are in the middle of titan season
three on hbo max everybody there is new
episodes every thursday so make sure you
check those out watch karen crush it as
usual as red hood as jason as robin who
knows who's going to play next yeah who
knows
who knows but curry thank you so much
for joining me man i hope to talk to you
in the future one day
thank you so much it was an honor thank
you